you're three and three pizzas only for  winners careful that pizzas gonna go  straight to your forehead that's all  bloomin mouth the mick you look at it  out boys what that manning face off your  face at least yarn Cooper he only has  one endorsement tuxedo Snuggie for all  your chewy formal events Mount Rushmore  this one's for the grand no pictures or  video on social media and what is it  gift your fine  drunk feel sleepy croc need hot brown  power juice caffeine the  performance-enhancing drugs you're fine  dry humping a Ned you're fine stop  moving you're fine  so sneezing define and suspended for a  week from Earth a dream come true a pool  of gold coins from all my ridiculous  finds all this never happened let ritual  duck